una noche de fiesta se volvió mortal
después de que un hombre armado abriera
fuego en varios lugares del concurrido
barrio de vida nocturna de oslo al menos
dos personas murieron y 21 resultaron
heridas 10 de ellas de gravedad- la
policía detuvo y acusó a un hombre de 42
años por asesinato intento de asesinato
y actos terroristas
tenemos al menos tres escenas del crimen
y nuestra evaluación general en este
momento es que hay razones para suponer
que su intención era sembrar un gran
temor en la población en general
wall street' y los hawks la policía dice
que el hombre un ciudadano noruego
originario de iran era conocido por las
autoridades pero no por delitos graves
uno de los objetivos fue un popular bar
gay llamado el london web lo que llevó a
algunos a preguntarse si podría tratarse
de un crimen de odio un testigo
describió los momentos de pánico
[Música]
había muchos que lloraban que gritaban
heridos que gritaban gente altera y
asustada muy muy asustada
los clientes estaban tirados en el suelo
dentro porque estaban muy asustados
el tiroteo tuvo lugar apenas unas horas
antes de que se iniciara el desfile
anual del orgullo de audio pero el
evento fue cancelado por los
acontecimientos violentos el desfile
queda cancelado según los consejos y
recomendaciones de la policía los
organizadores del desfile dijeron que
volverán a estar orgullosos y visibles
pero por ahora pidieron a la gente
celebrar el orgullo en casa